welcome to cloud security basics a
series where we explain the ins and outs
of securing your application on google
cloud
sound fun then stick around because in
this episode you'll learn about
cloud audit logging
[Music]
salutations cloud detective
last episode you used service accounts
to foil my grand attempt to compromise
your apps and scripts
that allow for automated access into
your system
this time i decided to go old school
one of your employees is logging in in
the middle of the night
and accessing things they shouldn't be
how do i know this well maybe it's
because you're not their only employer
the question is in a fully remote
workplace
how are you ever going to track down who
the wayward employee is
if you don't do something soon i just
might have to ask
our mutual employee to make some
unfortunate changes
to a slideshow how embarrassing would it
be if all of your images were replaced
with cats at the next company-wide
presentation
all right so here's what we know
admins are responsible for coming up
with solutions to the many ways users
can interact with their systems
and in this case we need to track down
who's accessing files
when they shouldn't be if this was at
the office
we could ask the security guards to walk
around and note if they see anything
suspicious
and if we were at the office we would
actually be able to look at the security
logs to see whose key card was being
used
to access the building late at night
wait a minute that gives me an idea
see google cloud provides a lot of tools
and services to protect
its users from cases just like this and
one of the most important tools
is called google cloud audit logs which
lets teams easily create
and manage audit logs regardless of how
carefully we code or
thoroughly we debug a piece of software
problems are gonna come up
and when they do it's almost impossible
to determine why they happened
and figure out how to fix them unless
there's a trail of breadcrumbs to follow
along the way
and security logging provides that
crucial trail of evidence
so during an active investigation or
post-mortem analysis
having regular logs to go through is
critical to identify the cause of the
issue they help establish baselines
and find operational trends logging
security events that keep track of
every activity that happens in the
digital environment
your organization will monitor these
logs for any suspicious activity or
unauthorized access to the system
whenever these breaches are found
the data is moved to a central database
so that the security team
can then investigate them
i need to investigate this more when it
comes to google's cloud audit logs
some types of logs like admin activity
logs
are on by default and can't be disabled
others like data access logs are
optional
off by default and cost money to use
logs that are not essential are turned
off by default to save users money
because the logs could take up a large
amount of data
that would apply against google's quotas
and limits
but depending on what you need cloud
audit logs provide
many customization options to suit an
organization
and fulfill all their security logging
needs
so these include the aforementioned
admin activity audit logs which cover
api
calls and admin actions that modify how
metadata for resources is configured
whenever vm instances are created or
identities are changed
a log record is kept these logs are
automatically kept
don't cost users anything and can't be
disabled
then there's data access audit logs
which keep track of users as they create
change and read data that's been user
provided
these do have costs associated with them
except for bigquery's data access audit
logs
and data access audit logs aren't on by
default because they can store
a lot of data and then there's system
event audit logs to track changes to how
resources are configured
these logs are triggered by google
systems don't
cost anything and can't be disabled
and finally there's policy denied audit
logs
those are created whenever a google
cloud service denies access to a user or
service account because of a security
policy violation
these are on by default but do have
costs associated with them
so we've got a lot of log information to
sort through
but it's important to understand that
audit logs have no concept of suspicious
events
and are often best effort items
that can be delayed by up to five
minutes
and still once your security team is
aware of a suspicious event
your team will need to have the correct
tools and data to work with
to assess the situation and take action
as appropriate
and luckily in our case we'd turned on
data access logs
so let's look at those and see who's
been calling what and when
and by taking a look at who's been
accessing files they
shouldn't have eureka i was
able to figure out who's been accessing
files they shouldn't
dratz you figured that out so quickly
although it does make me wonder why a
regular scan of activity wasn't already
part of your process
google cloud has tools that allow you to
set up real-time alerts and
notifications
and regardless of if you use those or
not your company should implement an
audit process that involves regularly
reviewing the logs for suspicious
behavior
so there you have it another episode of
cloud security basics
next episode we'll be looking into this
so-called security breach
so stay tuned for the rest of the cloud
security basics series
because when it comes to security you
can't let bad actors win
[Music]